Alexander Kähler
der Geist ist willig doch das Fleisch
ist schwach diese alte Erkenntnis zieht
sich durch inzwischen 27
Weltklimakonferenzen und ist jedes Mal
das einzig verlässliche Ergebnisse den
mehr oder minder ambitionierten von
Sharm el Sheikh wird es nicht anders
ergehen obwohl Feuer unterm Dach ist die
Erde fängt an aus den Fugen zu geraten
aber die Schmerzgrenze scheint für viele
noch immer nicht erreicht
Wettlauf gegen die Zeit was bringt der
Klimagipfel jetzt in der Phönix Runde
Phoenix Runde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
hier im Studio Lamia messari Becker ist
bei uns sie sind Bauingenieurin
Professorin für Gebäudetechnologie und
Bau Physik an der Universität Siegen
Experten für nachhaltiges Bauern hat mit
Klima sehr viel zu tun und sie sind
Mitglied des Club of Rome der
ältesten und einer der bedeutendsten
Umweltschutzorganisationen auf der Welt
letzten Tally ist bei uns die
blumenmeteologe bekannt vom ZDF als
Wettermoderator neben ihm der Platz ist
frei da müsste eigentlich Pauline
Brünner von Fridays for futuresic sitzen
die hat auf dem Weg hier ins Studio die
ebenso Umwelt wie klimafreundliche Bahn
benutzt und die Deutsche Bahn und das
ist der Grund warum sie noch nicht hier
ist und Daniel Gräber ist bei uns sie
leiden das Resort capital beim
debattenmagazin
Cicero
die Klimakonferenz haben wir heute Abend
gehört geht wahrscheinlich mal wieder in
die Verlängerung ist es eigentlich ein
gutes oder wie so oft an ihr schlechtes
Zeichen dass sich offenbar nicht einig
dieses Mal gibt's sogar noch nicht mal
im Vorfeld des Abschluss der der
Abschlusskonferenz ankommen die käme ja
deswegen wird es ja wahrscheinlich
verlängert weil es eben noch einiges zu
debattieren gibt erst einmal hauptsache
es kommt was bei rum und dann können Sie
es auch gerne verlängern ich hoffe es
kommt was vernünftiges mehr
Rebecca da kann die Weltklimakonferenz
beschließen was sie will zu Hause muss
es dann umgesetzt werden wo liegen denn
in der Praxis der
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen die größten Steine
im Weg die größten Steine liegen darin
dass sehr oft Ziele ambitionierte Ziele
formuliert werden aber keine
technologischen Lösungen mitgedacht
werden insofern muss Klimakonferenz auch
eine technologiegemeinschaft werden das
ist ein Punkt der zweite Punkt ist es
muss sozial gedacht werden das heißt
möglichst viele Menschen viele Länder
mitnehmen und dazu braucht diese
Klimakonferenz auch eine
vertrauensbildende Maßnahmen die 100
Milliarden US-Dollar die anschließend
neuen versprochen wurden 2015 in Pariser
Klimaabkommen festgeschrieben werden da
ist bisher nichts geflossen und dass sie
es verheerend für das
Vertrauensverhältnis
ja vor Ort in Sharm el Sheik um zu
retten was zu retten ist hilft es
eigentlich dem Klima das in Deutschland
grüne bündnisgrüne im Moment an den
schalthellen der Regierung setzen ich
würde sagen es schadet sogar dem Klima
weil wenn man sich anschaut während Frau
bärburg Klima Außenpolitik betreibt und
um die Welt chattet ist zu Hause im
entscheidenden Ministerium dem
Wirtschafts- und klimaschutzministerium
Herr habeg Amberg und er hat zuletzt
gezeigt dass er mit seinem Nein gegen
eine wirkliche atomkraftverlängerung
stattdessen Kohlekraftwerke zurück ans
Netz holt dass er damit den CO2 Ausstoß
von Deutschland nicht senkt sondern
erhöht
wir haben ja jetzt in den letzten 14
Tagen diese
Weltklimakonferenz Konferenz
aufzuparties das sind alle diejenigen
also Kopf alle diejenigen die dieses
Klima Rahmenabkommen unterzeichnet haben
haben wir jetzt erlebt das läuft immer
nach dem gleichen Ritus ab in die bei
diesen Klimakonferenzen ich glaube bis
zu 35.000 Personen sind da in dem
ägyptischen Badeort an der Südspitze des
Sinai Halbinsel versammelt wenn man sich
letzten Teile die letzten 14 Tage da
anguckt was da alles passiert ist wo
hackt eigentlich am meisten bei dieser
Konferenz
ja also aus meiner Sicht ist
also ganz klar da muss es zu einem
Ergebnis kommen aber die Frage ist
natürlich auch was macht die Ölindustrie
dort und was für ein Gewicht hat die
Ölindustrie dort weil das haben wir auch
in den letzten Konferenzen gesehen dass
da ja auch versucht wird quasi die
Ergebnisse zu verbessern und
also wenn wenn da nicht was vernünftiges
bei rumkommt ist das ein fatales Zeichen
die
ölgasindustrie hat ja da auch Lobbyisten
vor Ort es wird ja jetzt auch immer
wieder versucht offenbar von dieser
Seite
den Ausstieg aus den fossilen Energien
sozusagen der nicht festschreiben zu
lassen ist das klug im Moment
weiter auf fossile Energien auch als
Übergangs Energie zu setzen oder sollte
man vielleicht in einer langfristigen
Projektion Herr Kleber schon mal sagen
also das ist ja eigentlich nicht die
Zukunft um das Weltklima zu erhalten
nein also natürlich müssen wir
langfristig von den von der fossilen
Energieträgern wegkommen auch weil
letztendlich die Vorräte zwar noch
durchaus einige vorhanden sind auch in
Deutschland übrigens das Gas was bei uns
im Boden schlummert wird wird nicht
angepackt stattdessen holen mir ist mit
vielen schlechter Klima Bilanz aus den
USA jetzt also es gibt noch fossile
Brennstoffe eben auch nicht ewig aber
wir müssen natürlich um um den CO2
Ausstoß zu senken müssen wir natürlich
von den fossilen wegkommen bei dem sind
für uns alle einig bloß ich halte
überhaupt nichts davon dass ich
Politiker ob auf internationaler Ebene
wie jetzt bei dem Gipfel oder auf grünen
Parteitagen oder bei uns im Bundestag
darüber Gedanken machen was wann
abgeschafft werden soll und mit welcher
Jahreszahl sondern wir müssen doch viel
mehr positiv an die Sache rangehen in
was wollen wir investieren also lassen
wir die Gas und Öl Lobby machen was sie
wollen und schauen dass wir parallel
dazu in Wasserstoff investieren auch
Nuklearenergie vorantreiben in neuen
neue
Forschungsbereiche wo einiges viel
unterwegs ist gerade aber Deutschland
komplett den Anschluss verliert also wir
müssen doch gucken in was wollen wir
einsteigen bevor wir irgendwelche
ausstiegsbeschlüsse fassen die dann eh
nicht umzusetzen sind weil weil sie
nicht mehr zu vermitteln sind Bäcker
wird da wird dazu viel ist Symbolik in
diese Klimakonferenzen gesteckt von der
einen wie von der anderen Seite ja von
beiden Seiten das ist Stichwort was mir
fehlt ist einfach eine systemische
Herangehensweise an einen an die
Transformation des energie-systems also
ich muss doch einen Gesamtplan haben der
die Einstiege in Erneuerbaren mit den
ausstiegen aus fossilen abstimmt und
kombiniert und in der Übergangszeit
werden wir sicherlich noch fossile
Energien brauchen aber langfristig muss
ich doch diesen Plan aufstellen und das
vermisse ich total in Deutschland und
die Industrienation Deutschland macht
gerade vor wie es eben nicht geht und
das ist auch fatal für die Länder die
sehen nämlich dass die Energiewende so
wie Deutschland die aufgesattelt hat
nicht funktioniert und da brauchen wir
Korrekturen also hier im Land also nicht
weiter nur auf Wind und Photovoltaik
also nur auf die Strom Seite zu setzen
sondern auch Wärme mitzudenken also alle
anderen erneuerbaren Energien kurz um
alles zusammen kratzen was geht und das
Andere was hier völlig verschlafen wurde
ist natürlich der Aufbau von Speicher
Technologien Speicher Infrastruktur und
das dritte was Deutschland vormacht ist
das wir mit einem Umstieg auf
erneuerbaren Energien ist so verbockt
haben dass wir sämtliche Jobs verlieren
wir haben negative Beispiele aus der
Solarindustrie Windanlagen ich könnte
sagen als Ingenieuren auch die
Stahlunternehmen sind abgewandert und
ich befürchte ähnliches auch im
Bausektor der ja auch wichtig für die
Klimaschutzziele insofern ist wir müssen
irgendwie zeigen dass die
Klimaschutzziele vereinbar sind mit
einer Wertschöpfungskette eine
technologischen Wertschöpfungskette dass
die Länder sind aha es funktioniert und
das gelingt im Moment Deutschland
in regenerative Energien ist Deutschland
versuchen gerade in der Klimapolitik
auch Vorreiterrolle zu spielen oder den
Vorreiter zu spielen ist das
überschätzen wir uns da im Moment in
unserer Zeit auf jeden Fall also keine
Frage da müsste viel mehr passieren und
selbst die Ziele bis 2030 die sind ja
einzuhalten das wurde ja zuletzt auch
noch mal festgestellt und ich muss aber
wieder sprechen dass wir die Öl und
Gasindustrie machen lassen weil wenn sie
investieren ja sie sehen ja jetzt gerade
alles Boom und würden am liebsten weiter
investieren wir müssen raus aus den
Fossilien und das so schnell wie möglich
und das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie ein
irgendwie
in der Ukraine des Kriege klar aber aber
das muss das muss halt reduziert werden
und das ist es geht hier nicht um
Partikularinteressen von irgendwelchen
Parteien es geht hier darum dass man
runter muss damit weil es eben die der
Verursacher ist der Erhitzung und wenn
man das sieht Ursache und Wirkung da
gibt es überhaupt nicht zu diskutieren
da müssen wir raus hat übrigens das
haben wir auch ein Pariser Abkommen auch
so beschlossen und da gibt's eigentlich
gar nichts zu diskutieren wir müssen es
nur schnell machen denn je länger wir
warten desto größer wird das Risiko dass
wir bestimmte Grenzen überschreiten ne
die 1,5 Grad Marke z.B die kaum noch zu
halten ist
da da müssen wir ran und wenn ich sage
es ist kaum noch zu halten bedeutet das
nicht dass wir jetzt irgendwie uns
zurücklehnen und sagen aber wir schaffen
das eh nicht mehr sondern wir müssen
alles dran setzen trotzdem die Maßnahmen
für die um die um dieses Ziel zu halten
müssen wir quasi investieren so dass CO2
Emissionen ja die dumme physikalische
Eigenschaft haben nicht an nationalen
Grenzen Halt zu machen oder
beziehungsweise ein Land sauber zu
halten dass ich daran hält selbst wenn
wir jetzt nicht Musterschüler sind auf
der Welt die anderen großen Emittenten
also die die besonders viel ausstoßen an
CO2 China die USA Brasilien das sieht es
ja auch nicht besonders gut aus was
passiert eigentlich oder macht es Sinn
zu sagen wir gehen jetzt mal mit guten
Beispiel voran die anderen kommen
hinterher oder ist das sowas wie
Blauäugigkeit es ist glaube ich bei uns
war das ja in der Energiewende wie sie
dann ab 2011 mit mit dem ähm
Atomausstieg wird dann beschlossen wurde
wurde es ja als große nationale
kraftanstrengen ähm auch in Deutschland
mit so einem gewissen positiven
gemeinschaftsziel wir wollen jetzt da
voran und jetzt hat glaube ich also es
war schon vor dem Ukraine Krieg
abzusehen das ist einfach nicht hinhaut
wie man sich das ausgedacht hat und mit
dem Ukraine Krieg und jetzt den
gaslieferstopp hat Inhalt des Problem
gezeigt weil diese Einstieg in die
Erneuerbaren hat gleichzeitig auch zum
Ausbau des Gasbedarfs geführt und das
Gas fehlt uns jetzt und diese Probleme
fallen uns jetzt auf die Füße und
momentan ist es so wir wollten
eigentlich der Welt zeigen dass ein
Industrieland sich auf erneuerbare
umstellen kann im Moment zeigen wir der
Welt sind wir eigentlich ein
abschreckendes Beispiel wie man es nicht
macht aber das ist ja das ist ja eine
Sache die ja in den letzten 16 Jahren
vermasselt wurde ja also da sind wir
auch eine nicht das ist eine Tatsache
dass die Windindustrie abgewirtschaftet
wurde die Solarindustrie bzw umgekehrt
anstatt damals massiv auszubauen dann
würden wir jetzt ganz anders da stehen
sie sich mal an die aus die Ausbau
Kurven diesen eindeutig es gibt einen
Einbruch bei der Solarindustrie das
wissen Sie ja wahrscheinlich also 2012
da ging es dann abwärts ja da da
Hersteller meinen Sie jetzt die
Hersteller das war politisch politische
entsprechend nicht bei den installierten
Anlagen sondern Einbruch bei den
Solarzellen Herstellern genau weil einer
polieren naja es geht ja um die
politische
Rahmenbedingungen geht dass wir Energie
haben wollen dann ist es egal ob die
photovoltaikelle in China hergestellt
wurde hauptsächlich auf unserem Dach
würde ich jetzt sagen
naja also sie müssen es auch wieder
importieren und jetzt sind wir von China
abhängig ne also jetzt da wird jetzt
viele hergestellt aber eigentlich
eigentlich ist das ja wir wollen doch
nicht die Industrie weggeben es wird
auch schön gewesen wenn die
solarindustriegeblieben wäre genauso wie
die
Windanlagen auch da würde auch nicht
genug ausgebaut wenn hätte man das
entsprechend weitergeführt würden wir
jetzt besser da stehen und müssten nicht
so viel Gas importieren das sind auch
Tatsachen oder Frage erweitern wir es
fehlen es hilft Solar es fehlt Wind
Energie das ist ähm es ist bekannt es
gibt große Widerstände gegen den Bau von
Wind und Solarparks es fehlt aber auch
der Nachschub Rohstoffe Fachkräfte die
Montage und die politischen Widerstände
der Gegend
kann ich zwar sagen in acht Jahren wäre
es gut wenn wir fast nur noch
regenerative Energie haben nur das wird
ja schon allein wegen dieser
Faktoren also wie gesagt
Fachkräftemangel Rohstoffmangel und
politischer Widerstand gar nicht
funktionieren es ist richtig dass wir
wirklich Fachkräftemangel haben so dass
die Bauwirtschaft zum Flaschenhals
praktisch aller Klimaschutzziele werden
kann deshalb brauchen wir aufbaupläne
personalaufbaupläne und langfristige
Investition so dass die Bauwirtschaft
sieht es wird eine langfristige Aufgabe
für uns geben deshalb können wir auch
Fachkräfte aufbauen das wird aber nicht
das gesamte Problem lösen denn ähm wir
haben es ist die Aufgabe der Zukunft ist
nicht mehr Ausbau alleine sondern wir
müssen auch anders ausbauen was wir
beispielsweise eben nicht dafür gesorgt
haben ist die Speicher Strukturen die
Speicherkapazitäten das ist ein fataler
Fehler der Politik und auch in der
wissensbasierten Politikberatung da gibt
es immer noch die Behauptung wir hätten
Speicher noch nicht also wir müssen
wirklich aus den erneuerbaren Strom was
nutzbar produzieren und liefern also die
erneuerbare Energie nutzbar machen das
ist eine extrem wichtige Aufgabe und das
dritte vielleicht wenn Sie mögen ist
dass wir aus diesem Grund der
Rohstoffknappheit dringend auch eine
Kreislaufwirtschaft etablieren müssen
die Ressourcen effizientes Ressourcen
bewusst ist die Material maximal sparsam
einsetzt und sie immer im kreislaufe das
gilt für die Bauwirtschaft das gilt aber
auch für erneuerbare Energien für
Elektromobilität und all das und da sind
wir eigentlich dass wir die Rohstoffe
für so vielen mit diesen Ziel nicht
wirklich haben müssen
wir definieren immer Ziele also das 1,5
Grad Ziel gegenüber der Temperatur der
Durchschnittstemperatur in der
vorindustriellen Zeit also vor 1800 etwa
wir sagen in der Europa so zwischen 2045
und 50 wollen wir klimaneutral sein nur
der Weg dahin ist unklar fehlt da eine
man hätte neudeutsch Roadmap also dass
er ein Planung eine eine Wege Karte zu
diesem Ziel was da genau passieren muss
was wir erreichen müssen in der
Zwischenzeit damit auch diese Ziele
realistisch sind in vielen klingt das
was wir da hören das sind die glaube ich
auch nicht alleine als ziemlich ja über
ambitioniert um nicht zu sagen utopisch
ja also ich würde dafür plädieren lieber
die Ziele man muss sie sich setzen weil
sonst erreicht man nichts aber ich würde
wäre lieber dafür die Ziele ein bisschen
realistischer zu formulieren und dann
auch nicht von Wahl zur Wahl jetzt
machen wir noch schnelleren Cola
ausstieg und man hat ja gesehen wo es
hin für das funktioniert ja nicht die
Zahlen sind ja
aber Unsinn und dann stattdessen eine
was mir fehlt vor allem ist eine
langfristige Strategie wie viel
Deutschland ein Industrieland bleiben
wie will Deutschland eine sichere und
vor allem auch bezahlbare
Energieversorgung mit dem Ziel der
Umwelt oder Klimafreundlichkeit
kombinieren da hat Deutschland keinen
Plan momentan weil die was jetzt immer
gepredigt wird wir brauchen noch mehr
Solar und noch mehr windkraft ist zwar
richtig dass wir es brauchen aber wir
uns fehlen die Speicher weil ich glaube
viele Menschen und ich befürchte fast
auf viele Politiker gar nicht verstanden
wie das Stromnetz eigentlich
funktioniert das Stromnetz muss immer es
muss in jeder Sekunde genauso viel Strom
erzeugt werden wie Verbrauch wird
genauso viel sogar eine Grund das
schaffen einfach Wind und
wetterabhängige Energiequellen schaffen
das einfach nicht und es wurde komplett
versäumt das zu lösen und deswegen
brauchen wir die Kraftwerke also es
sollten Gaskraftwerke sein jetzt auf
einmal auch nicht mehr weil das Gas
jetzt dafür fehlt und aus meiner Sicht
bleibt für die Übergangszeit bleiben die
Atomkraftwerke und ich halte es für den
größten Fehler dass wir jetzt nicht die
sechs die wir noch haben wirklich für
ein paar Jahre
Mitte April abgesichert haben bis wann
wollen Sie die denn bis wann wollen Sie
denn bauen die brauchen erst einmal
planen die die wir schon die noch
sterben weil das sind ja auch nur wenige
Prozent die die liefern und das das
Problem lösen die ja damit auch nicht
also im Prinzip ist ist da ein Defizit
ganz klar aber das Problem ein bisschen
sie lösen vor allem das kohleproblem
weil was jetzt was passiert
dieser Fokus auf CO2 der ist wirklich
fatal weil man sieht dadurch haben wir
also durch die Krise jetzt mehr Kohle
das ist fatal für die CO2 Bilanz wir
importieren LNG das ist mit einer
schlechteren CO2-Bilanz als Braunkohle
und wenn man jetzt nur auf CO2
fokussiert wäre dann müssten eigentlich
die AKWs laufen und deshalb bin ich als
Mitglied im Körperform dann doch für
alle Ziele also wir haben hier 17 ist
die die 17 Nachhaltigkeitsziele da ist
Klima ganz wichtig aber da ist auch der
Kampf gegen Armut da ist sie da ist der
Zugang zu sauberem Trinkwasser
Trinkwasser da ist auch der Zugang zu
bezahlbarer saubere Energie bezahlbar
und deshalb muss muss erneuerbare
Energien für extrem günstig werden damit
die gesamte Welt davon profitieren kann
damit sind wir zurück wir haben jetzt
über die in politische Situation was was
Klima angesprochen weil wir wollen ja
auch auf den Klima Gipfel schauen da
geht's ja auch ums Geld also das kostet
auch bei uns ist eine Unmenge Geld die
Energiewende das wird niemand bezweifeln
das gilt weltweit natürlich erst recht
jetzt haben gerade die
Entwicklungsländer immer wieder
Entschädigungen gefordert für die
Klimaschäden die die Industrieländer
beim Aufbau ihrer Industrie in den
letzten Jahrzehnten und Jahrhunderten
auch ihres Wohlstands verursacht haben
und zwar zum Schaden der
Entwicklungsländer das nennt sich lost
and damage also eine Art
Entschädigungszahlung das kommt auch
noch dazu man könnte jetzt noch Unmengen
von anderen Bereichen aufzählen die zwar
mit den 100 Milliarden Unterstützung in
die Richtung noch weitere Unterstützung
für Entwicklungsländer gerade in Afrika
bei diesen Finanzierungsvolumen wie
realistisch ist das eigentlich was man
sich da vorgenommen hat es fehlt ja
dieses Geld noch obwohl es ja schon vor
Jahren angekündigt wurde so wenig so gut
wie nicht und das ist natürlich ein
verheerender werden Signal es braucht
diese funktionsbildende Maßnahme
wirklich aber es wird trotzdem nicht
reichen deshalb ist es wichtig
klimathemen mit anderen Themen zu
verbinden damit auch für die Länder eine
Wertschöpfungskette daraus generiert
wird ich bin auch sehr für
energiekooperationen mit mit dem Ausland
aber vor Ort in Afrika kann es nicht nur
darum gehen wir produzieren Energie und
exportieren sondern es muss für die
Jugend insbesondere dort auch eine
Perspektive erfolgen also durch
Technologie durch Bildung durch
Forschung so kann es sein dass dann die
Länder auch wirklich diesen Marsch gehen
und Mitmachen so sehe ich das ähm und
was was er ja auch verheerend ist das
Chinas war heute fast ein Drittel
produziert aber es ist ausgerechnet das
Land also die verfehlen auch Ihre Ziele
und es ist das Land was die Technologie
praktisch kopiert am Ende und ähm davon
profitiert aber trotzdem die Ziele nicht
erreicht und nicht bereit ist in diesem
großen Form von 100 Milliarden bezahlen
die größte Wüste der Erde die könnte man
mit sogar Solarmodul regelrecht
bestücken vollstellen dort ist Sonne
ohne Ende vorhanden eine Energiequelle
die nichts kostet die in riesigen Mengen
da ist es auch Platz dort zum Beispiel
Solarstrom zu erzeugen die Investitionen
in regenerative Energien im letzten Jahr
auf der ganzen Welt liefen 0,6% nach
Afrika das heißt diese Frage wie man
überhaupt mit
Zukunftstechnologie mit Projekten umgeht
da läuft ja unglaublich viel falsch wenn
man jetzt wird dass man eigentlich da wo
man es bräuchte gar kein Geld reinsteckt
ja also ich meine einerseits ist es so
dass das Solarzellen ja und Photovoltaik
er eigentlich die billigste Energieform
mittlerweile ist also Atomkraftwerke neu
aufbauen oder
Kohlekraftwerke das ist ja eigentlich
alles viel zu teuer ne ähm eigentlich
ist es zu teuer und ähm das wäre
eigentlich optimal in solchen Ländern
gerade wo viel Sonnenschein ist quasi
auf Photovoltaik aufzubauen und da
da muss man natürlich auch die Länder
dran beteiligen und was wir vielleicht
hier gerade überhaupt gar nicht
besprechen ist vielleicht dass wir das
so oder so machen müssen diesen Schritt
zur regenerativen weil wir haben gar
keine andere Chance wir können eben
keine fossilen weiter verbrennen das ist
das passt einfach nicht ins Budget und
wenn wir dieses Budget was wir ja eben
haben wenn wir das Überschreiten
überschreiten halt bestimmte
temperaturmarker das bedeutet dass die
ähm dass die dass die globale
Mitteltemperatur sagen wir die 1,5 Grad
Marke überschritten wird 1,5 und 2 Grad
das ist ein riesen Unterschied das
klingt so wenig aber es ist global
betrachtet Lokal kann das bedeuten dass
es viel heißer wird zum Beispiel in
Europa zum Beispiel in Deutschland ne
also wir haben den letzten Sommer
gesehen wie die Temperatur ähm gestiegen
ist was für wie der Sommer war war
davon können Sie ausgehen das war ja der
wärmste Sommer in Europa das war der
wärmste Sommer jetzt runter gebrochen in
in Deutschland und der wärmste oktober
in Frankreich in Österreich in der
Schweiz und in Deutschland wir haben
massive Schmelze bei den Gletschern
beobachtet da haben sie teilweise
gletscherabschmelze von 6 Metern also
ich rede jetzt nicht von sechs Metern an
der Gletscherzunge am Ende wo der
Gletscher zu Ende geht sondern ein
Volumen von sechs Metern ist von oben
nach unten abgeschmolzen das ist ein
massiver Verlust wir haben also in
diesem Sommer einen wirklich ein extrem
Sommer erlebt so ähm und wir haben seit
fünf Jahren vier Dürre Jahre die extrem
sind wo einfach das Wasser fehlt und sie
müssen sich das so vorstellen das Wasser
kann man jetzt nicht einfach ausgleichen
also ich rede jetzt von Regen ne das
fehlt uns einfach da müsste es ja
eigentlich ja für ja viel mehr regnen
damit Sie diesen Wasserhaushalt wieder
ausgleichen passiert aber nicht so das
bedeutet dass wir mit einem Defizit
weiter in die folgenden Jahre gehen und
die Projektion des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes zeigen eindeutig bis Ende
des Jahrzehnts wird Deutschland wärmer
Europa wird wärmer Europa ist Hotspot
einer der Hotspots in auf dem Planeten
der Kontinente also von den ganzen
Kontinenten ist es der Hotspot wo die wo
die Temperatur so geschildert ist denn
diese diese sind diese Kipppunkte
vielleicht schon erreicht die man sagt
also es gibt immer es gibt eine Studie
die Studie die Kamera in diesem Sommer
raus vom pick ähm die zeigt für Klima
Folgen Forschung ja die zeigt dass
zwischen 1 und 1,5 Grad bereits
Kipppunkte getriggert sind ja also zum
Beispiel die beste Antarktis man geht ja
davon aus dass das schon getriggert ist
und auch weitere ganz schlimm ist es
wenn irgendwann quasi Grünland stärker
schmitzt wir haben schon massive
Verluste im Grönland oder wie gesagt auf
den Gletschern aber wenn wir Grönland
uns anschauen dass diese Eismasse ragt
ihr bis 3 km hoch ganz kurz wenn es sich
weiter aufheizt und diese Eismasse sinkt
sinkt sie in eine bestimmte Region wo es
warm ist und dann beschleunigt sich das
und es kann eben auch zu Rutschungen
kommen wo quasi massiv viel Eis verloren
geht also der die Klimakatastrophe ich
nenne es eine Katastrophe weil nur weil
sie bei uns in Deutschland keine
Katastrophe ist bedeutet das nicht dass
sie woanders auf dem Planeten das nicht
ist die Klimakatastrophe ist die Pandora
ist die Büchse der Pandora ja wir wissen
nicht genau wann wo was diese Kipppunkte
mit einer interagieren und dann sich
noch verstärken deswegen ist es auch so
wichtig dass wir so schnell wie möglich
also wir reden ja von 1,5 Grad Marke die
wir bis Ende des jahrhundert eigentlich
nicht überschreiten wollen ne aber die
haben wir ja eigentlich fast schon so
aber wir wollen diese diese Marke ist
eigentlich auch schon zu hoch wir haben
jetzt schon zwischen 1 Grad und 1,2 Grad
schon diese massiven Veränderungen auf
dem Planeten ja was soll denn bei 1,5°
sein Wasser bei zwei sein und die
Projektion sind jetzt 2,8 bis 3 Grad und
eine eine durchgehende Anpassung an eine
fortschreitende Erhitzung ist nicht
möglich weil es enorme Ressourcen
verbrauchen würde bis zu einem
bestimmten Punkt und irgendwann macht
sich das ganze System selbstständig weil
der Planet noch Einsatz weil der Planet
auf unserer handeln wird auf diese
Erhitzung und dann haben wir echt
ja dann haben wir ein Problem aber
gewaltiges also was mich vielleicht
ergänzen was die Kipppunkte angeht diese
Szenarien angeht glaube ich hier
niemanden in der Runde dabei der das
wirklich diese Modelle errechnet hat was
ich weiß ist natürlich dass diese Punkte
von ähm ja da sind Studien das sind
Analysen und es gibt aber auch ähm
Klimaforscher beispielsweise Max
planungsinstitut in Hamburg die sagen
genau das Gegenteil es gibt eigentlich
nicht den Freund auf eine return dieser
sagen es lohnt sich immer gegen
zu kämpfen und es ist nicht so dass alle
so irre Version deshalb ist mir zum
Beispiel als Bauingenieurin wichtig dass
wir auch am Boden darauf reagieren
Stichwort Klimaanpassung nicht nur hier
sondern auch gerade die ärmeren Länder
die jetzt schon unter den Klimawandel
leiten und ich glaube dass auch noch
sehr viel Potenzial wo klimaschädten
irreversibel sind wenn ich sie jetzt
richtig so verstehe ich die Kamera
auch in Potsdam also dass die jetzt
nicht sagen das ist vollkommen verloren
wir stehen am Abgrund sozusagen sondern
wir können das noch schaffen eben durch
diese Maßnahmen die wir besprechen
bestimmte Punkte eben nicht und das z.B
die Weste Antarktis die von unten
angeknabbert wird vom Warmwasser das
können sie nicht umdrehen sie können
Eismassen die abgeschmolzen sind über
tausende von Jahren angewachsen sind
oder noch über längere Zeiträume die
können sie nicht wieder aufbauen das
wäre ja das reversible umso wichtiger
wirklich noch technologieoffener zu sein
und nicht nur überminderung zu sprechen
durch Ausbau Erneuerbaren aber wir
müssen auch über CO2 als Rohstoff
sprechen also Youtube auch Potsdam mal
da dran es gibt natürlich auch die CO2
Speicherung die wir hier verteufeln aber
in Norwegen Einkaufen also es gibt schon
Abkommen haben CO2 nach Norwegen zu
schaffen um sie aus der Atmosphäre
rauszuziehen gerade in Norden behindert
also wir zeigen gerade wie es nicht geht
wir reden von CO2 Budget schließen aber
uns alle Wege dahin und sagen das reicht
nicht das reicht nicht um 1,5
technologieoffenheit geht oder auch die
wirtschaftliche Frage von Klimaschutz
jetzt dieses Beispiel dass ich da
gebracht habe dass man ja in der Sahara
riesige Felder von Solarmodulen
installieren könnte und das so wenig
investiert wird warum ist das eigentlich
so das wäre doch ein ganz lohnendes
Objekt gerade wenn Solarstrom etwas ist
dass man billig kriegen kann auch
vielleicht auch teuer dann wieder
verkaufen kann warum wird gerade das so
wenig investiert warum fokussieren wir
uns nur auf den Windpark hier in
Deutschland das machen wir gar nicht nur
also Moment momentan ist glaube ich
allen in der Energiewirtschaft
ist vollkommen klar diese Idee die in
Deutschland auch immer noch so
rumgeistert Deutschland könne sich zu
100 Prozent regenerativ selbst versorgen
das ist ja so ein Bild was irgendwie
mitschwimmt das ist eigentlich
vollkommen klar dass das überhaupt nicht
möglich ist also wenn wir von irgendwann
mal 100% regenerativ sprechen und dann
eben auch nicht nur den Strom sondern
auch Wärme also das ist ja noch viel
mehr und und was wir für den Verkehr
brauchen
wir Deutschland immer ein Import wir
werden immer auf Energie importer
angewiesen sein die Idee ist ja genau
und da ist ja die Idee wenn man davon
regenerativ spricht ähm ist ja kommt da
jetzt momentan der Wasserstoff ins Spiel
das das wird jetzt als die Wasserstoff
wird als das Öl das das ist
bezeichnet und da findet momentan
durchaus ein Wettrennen statt auf der
Welt bei dem Deutschland leider
hinterher hängt dabei wäre es die Chance
auch für den deutschen Mittelstand für
den Maschinenbau in diese ganze
wasserstoffinfrastruktur zu investieren
dort auch Technik bei uns zu entwickeln
und dann ist es ehrlich gesagt erlauben
Sie mir das vollkommen egal ob wir bei
uns auf der Schwäbischen Alb noch drei
Windräder mehr oder weniger aufstellen
wenn wir hier die Technik produzieren
die weltweit zum Einsatz kommt um den
Umstieg auf dem wasserstoffmodell wo man
eben mit regenerativen Energie
Wasserstoff erzeugt und den dann
transportierbar und speicherbar macht in
Tankern in Pipelines und alle Anlagen
die man dazu braucht wenn wenn wir die
in Deutschland bauen dann haben wir dort
das wird die das könnte unsere
Autoindustrie werden da könnten wir
könnten wir wirklich uns retten und das
wird blockiert in Deutschland unter
anderem mit folgendem Argument ähm man
ist sich nicht ganz einig was denn jetzt
als grüner Wasserstoff gilt weil man hat
Angst dass die Franzosen oder sonst wäre
mit Atomkraft Wasserstoff macht und und
deswegen musste quasi mit regenerativer
Energie
lassen sie uns nochmal auf die
internationale Ebene zurückkehren jetzt
im angesichts dieses klimakipfels in
Chanel Sheikh häufig ist es ja auch von
politischen Konstellationen in einzelnen
Ländern in großen wichtigen Ländern
Brasilien hatte bisher ein Präsident der
sich da ein feuchten kehrrichtung
geschert hat um Klimaschutz in den USA
aber auch der Wechsel von Trump zu
beiden hatte einen solchen Effekt wie
jetzt von bolsonaro zu Luna der das
wieder verstärkt gerade auch den
Amazonas schützen will das hängt sehr
stark immer von politischen Konjunkturen
ab und auch von der Frage unter anderem
wie ich mit Demokratie umgehe in meinem
Land das gilt ganz besonders für Trump
und bolsonaro die gleichzeitig aber die
Klimaschutzpolitik verteufelt haben ist
eine große Gefahr für die für die
Entwicklung des Klimas ich sehe einen
großen Gefahr insbesondere wenn die
Klimaschutz Debatte so moralisiert so
ideologisiert abläuft und das ist ein
spezielle deutsche Geschichte wir
brauchen eigentlich ist das eine
überschaubare Aufgabe wenn man die
richtige Methoden und Wege an geht es
ist eine eine Frage von technologischer
und soziale Innovation ist also
Klimawandel ist lösbar wenn wir das
wirklich ernst nehmen und natürlich ist
jetzt für die Klimakonferenz ganz
wichtig zu schauen wie die Spannungen
sind aber die gute Nachricht ist ja das
ist nicht dazu geführt hat dass jetzt
irgendwie das Klima hinten ranfällt
sondern es ist zu erwarten dass
zumindest mal die Außenministerin
Werbung ein ein Finanzinstrument
vorschlägt mit es ist vielleicht ein
Mosaikstein womit man damit anfängt
solche Kooperationen zu finanzieren
Klimaanpassung zu finanzieren da ist sie
dabei und wenn das ihr gelingt mit
anderen Ländern wäre das tatsächlich in
dieser Klimakonferenzen großer Schritt
ich muss noch da noch mal rein grätschen
weil die Aussage des Klima
Klimakrise ist lösbar ist gibt ein
falsches Bild ab das ist einfach wenn
man das Richtige tut oder wollen Sie
oder nein
darf ne das ist doch Quatsch
ich habe ja gerade ich habe noch nie ich
habe noch nicht Hallo ich habe noch
nicht mal angefangen zu argumentieren
und sie brechen da voll rein die
Klimakrise geht ist ist im vollen Gange
und als Lösung was wäre was ist denn die
Lösung das einzige was wir erreichen
können ist das Abflachen der Erhitzung
das ist das einzige aber das ist keine
Lösung es wird trotzdem weiterhin für
Zerstörung sorgen und ich weiß gar nicht
was jetzt sind ja ja genau
kurz nachfragen also das heißt
eigentlich ist es kaum noch rückgängig
zu machen sind hier in dem Zustand also
aus ihrer Sicht dass wir nur noch das
Schlimmste verhindern können
na ja das ja sowieso das ja sowieso weil
sie wenn wir auf dem Fahrrad
weitermachen so wie jetzt und das ist
nicht meine Meinung dass ein
gewissenschaftler so Moment Moment reden
wenn das sich weiter fortsetzt sind wir
ja bei einer Zerstörung von zweieinhalb
bis zwei
drei Grad etwa und das ist eben eine
Zerstörung da können wir uns nicht
anpassen und das was wir schon haben die
Veränderung auf dem Planeten das läuft
ja noch weiter auch wenn wir sofort aus
den fossilen aussteigen würden wird das
ja noch weitergehen also es gibt nicht
dieses Klimakrise lösen es ist ein
abdämpfen das ist gerade mal möglich und
die Technologie an sich ist ja auch
irgendwo das Problem weil wir brauchen
ja auch Energie um diese Technologien zu
zu installieren wenn sie CO2 aus der
Atmosphäre rausziehen wollen ich habe
nichts dagegen werden kann da forschen
ohne Ende aber es ist einfach im Moment
nicht praktikabel und als Option auch
einfach schwierig weil es weil es auch
von denen dann benutzt wird und zwar
übrigens wirklich ideologisch um in die
Zukunft das immer weiter zu schieben und
ähm was wir machen müssen ist Reduktion
der der fossilen Energieträger daran
kommen wir einfach nicht vorbei und
natürlich können wir auch weiterhin
Technologien
benutzen aber das ist jetzt nicht die
Lösung wir müssen raus aus den fossilen
die Frage ist nur wann gelingt uns das
es wird ja auch immer gesagt sein
Brückentechnologie die haben wir so
lange bis die regenerative in großem
Umfang zur Verfügung stellt steht es ist
jetzt beschlossen worden 2035 in Europa
keine Autos mehr mit Verbrennungsmotor
zu bauen wie lange wird das dauern wie
lang ist diese die wie lange müssen wir
damit rechnen selbst wenn wir aus den
fossilen Energieträgern raus wollen wie
lange brauchen sie trotzdem noch
da mag ich mir sorry ich länger als
länger glaube ich als wir es uns
momentan ausdenken und das Wichtige ist
wie gesagt dass wir eben parallel halt
in neue Technologien einsteigen und
natürlich auch uns also wir müssen
beides machen wir müssen uns natürlich
auch an die Erde Werbung anpassen wenn
ich sehe wie zum Beispiel dieses
Hochwasser im Aartal wenn uns nicht mal
unsere Katastrophe wir reden hier vom
Klimakatastrophe und unsere
Katastrophenschutzbehörde kriegt das
nicht mal hin den Leuten die Leute
rechtzeitig aus dem Bett zu kriegen und
dass sie nicht dass sie nicht ertrinken
in den Fluten das war ja das war ja
katastrophal und dann wird hinterher
kleben sich die Leute die Jugendlichen
auf die Straße oder die Studenten und
und wollen die Welt retten dann fangen
wir doch bitte mal damit an den
Katastrophenschutz wir müssen uns beides
wir müssen uns da vorbereiten
wichtiges Thema das verbrennerverbot ist
der nächste sind indem wir reinlaufen es
gibt es ist natürlich hat müssen wir auf
Diesel und Benzin davon müssen wir
runterkommen aber ob es nur die
batterieelektrik ist weiß jetzt noch
kein Mensch das weiß niemand in der
Autoindustrie das weiß niemand in der
Politik weder in der EU noch sonst wo
wir können das Ziel vorgeben wir wollen
den CO2-Ausstoß im Verkehr senken und
müssen da aber wie wir das erreichen
müssen wir doch bitte Ingenieuren und
und der Wirtschaft überlassen was ist
denn ihr Vorschlag also das
effizienteste ist nun mal die
Batterietechnik wenn Sie jetzt eine
bessere Technik haben
ja das ist Batterie deswegen ist die
Industrie ja auf dem Weg dahin die
machen das ist auf dem Weg dorthin weil
sie von der Politik dazu gedrängt wird
verifiziert ist sie können
Behinderung Anpassung und dich versuchen
natürlich andere Variante sind
technologieoffenheit wir haben ja alle
Technologien Technologie
auch wenn wir uns über die Begriff ich
eigentlich den sie sagen das bleibt so
CO2 sind wir uns eigentlich bleibt ja
hunderte von Jahren in der Atmosphäre
also wir können das abflachen aber auch
das wäre für mich eine Lösung es ist
jetzt schon klar dass selbst bei 1,5
Grad Ziel einige Länder die Inselgruppen
untergehen war also hören wir brauchen
keine Anpassung wir müssen dringend auch
uns anpassen um auch diese Länder auch
helfen zu können gewesen also ich habe
jetzt mach mal dann kurz ein Break dass
ihr sagen also wir wissen einsparen wir
müssen raus aus bestimmten
Energieträgern wir wissen neue pushen
und vor allen Dingen wir müssen durch
Technologie diesen Effekt auch noch
verstärken durch ähm vom grünen
Wasserstoff bis hin zu der Frage wie wir
möglichst energieeffizient in Zukunft
produzieren und auch leben diese
Stichwort mit den Inselstaaten meine
Lieben Tuvalu und war nur die beiden
letzten bekannt bei uns in der Südsee
archipeline die sind ja sozusagen am
absaufen was jedenfalls relativ groß
dass sie steigenden Meeresspiegel
irgendwann mal verschwinden zum Tuvalu
ist glaube ich ganz besonders gefährdet
da siedelt man schon Menschen um das
sind die unmittelbaren Folgen dieser
dieses Klimawandels ist da was ist da
eigentlich oder wie versuchen wir diesen
den schwächsten Gliedern in dieser Kette
zu helfen ja das ist uns auch im
Körperform extrem wichtig weil es ist
eine Frage der Gerechtigkeit wer hat für
was verursacht und wer leidet darunter
und es ist ganz klar dass die
Industrienationen dass in diesen Klima
Konferenzen auch eine Lösung gefunden
werden muss für diese Länder und das ist
auch wieder anpassen du normalerweise
weil dort eben keine also selbst bei 1,5
werden einige Länder untergehen und da
braucht sie jetzt Schutz nicht nur im
Katastrophenfall also die Sport globaler
Schutzschirm was Außenministerium
aufgelegt hat sondern auch ein gefühltes
Topf für Klima also ein klimafond und
auch Zahlungen der Industrieländern
damit man dort auch wirklich also ich
will jetzt nicht sagen evakuieren aber
wir müssen natürlich eine Lösung für die
finden ist doch völlig klar
ist doch völlig klar deshalb ist
Anpassung für mich Hand in Hand mit
Klimaschutz ist es kein entweder oder
sondern sowohl alles auch und ich könnte
auch über anpassen eigentlich auch alles
definieren also wir passen unser
Wirtschaft unsere Art zu wirtschaften
die sportkreislaufwirtschaft wir passen
unser Energie-System an also von Fossil
zu erneuerbar wir passen unser
Mobilitätsverhalten von immer mehr Autos
in den Städten hin zu Stadt der kurzen
Wege also das ist für mich auch alles
anpassen sonst ist deshalb ist für mich
dieses Wort verzeihen Sie mir das
absolut positiv belegt das ist kein
Ablenkungsmanöver was in Deutschland so
bezeichnet wird offenbar für mich ist
das gehört absolut zusammen das ist das
ist eine deutsche noch kurz zum Anpassen
ein ein gutes Beispiel habe ich auch
noch zu dem weil was mich der
grundsätzlich wirklich wirklich besorgt
diese Technologie Feindlichkeit in
Teilen der deutschen klima-bewegung also
wirklich das ist eine eher für mich so
eine fast schon religiöse Bewegung die
irgendwie den den Weltuntergang nicht
herbei sind aber irgendwie auch was
faszinierendes daran hat und so ein
zurück zur und wir müssen etwas das hat
teilweise wirklich schon was
irrationales für das ist jetzt Quatsch
nein es ist nicht das ist das ist
richtiger Unsinn also überlegen sie noch
mal ob sie das wirklich weiterführen
wollen das ist wirklich Unsinn diese
Technologiefeindlichkeit die damit
schwingt zeigt sie zum Beispiel auch
beim Thema Gentechnik da Anpassung geht
es auch darum wie können wir wie können
wir die wachsende Menschheit zukünftig
auch in trockeneren Gebieten ernähren
oder kann Gentechnik eine ganz wichtige
Rolle spielen dass wir Getreidesorten
und anderes entwickeln die mit dem mit
dem Klimaerwärmung klar kommt wir sind
jetzt in Deutschland ist das ja das
Teufel Projekte vom Auswärtigen Ampeln
dass sie beruhigen kann Hitze resistente
Ernährung Resistenz haben
Sie eine Idee wenn das immer
Fortschreiten sich weiter erwärmt das
müssen wir ganz sicher
wir haben das Problem
eine Anpassung nämlich an die Sendezeit
ja aber in der Zielgeraden nicht beim
Klimaschutz leider sondern in der
Sendung
was sagte immer am besten wenn man etwas
kritisiert und sie haben das ja sehr
dunklen Farben jetzt alles gemalt dann
fängt man am besten bei sich selbst an
was bedeutet denn das eigentlich für uns
die meisten von uns Leben im Wohlstand
sie brauchen unglaublich viele
Ressourcen die wir eigentlich auch für
andere Dinge bräuchten was was können
wir da eigentlich machen was kann jeder
Einzelne da tun also diese dieser
Gedanke dass jeder einzelne die Welt
retten kann das können wir erstmal
anfängt ja Sie können sie können alles
mögliche probieren die die den CO2
Ausstoß abzusehen sie können weniger
konsumieren und so weiter aber sie
kommen unter eine bestimmte Schwelle
nicht runter weil die Straßenbahn
draußen ja auch fährt die ja auch im sie
müssen es ja auf Ihr Budget berechnen da
kommen sie nicht runter so also kann es
eigentlich nur funktionieren oder die
Autos die Autobahnen gebaut werden und
so weiter und so weiter ne ähm sie
müssen das quasi
in Bahn lenken und dafür sind Gesetze da
und sie müssen halt Vorgaben machen und
das ist ja auch nichts Negatives das ist
kein Verbot sondern sie geben der
Industrie ja auch einen Rahmen wo sie
investieren kann ja also es wird ja ich
drehe das jetzt mal um ne umgekehrte
wird immer Verbot Verbot und es ist eben
kein Verbot wenn wir dieses Problem
lösen wollen wie sie sagen dann müssen
wir halt irgendwie auch versuchen das
wirklich schnell zu machen und das geht
eben nur mit Effizienz mit Gesetzen an
die wir uns dann alle halten weil sie
können ja noch so viel einschränken ich
kann so viel einschränken wenn andere
das nicht tun haben wir nichts erreicht
es gibt viele Abkommen aus denen ja
solche Gesetze fließen sollen aber
bisher ist auch tatsächlich zu wenig
passiert ja 40 ist keine Lösung 40 ist
eine luxuslösung die kann sich auch
Industrie Nationen gerne leisten aber
wenn ich auf die Milliarden Menschen in
Afrika in asienblicke geht es dort um
neue um andere Bedürfnisse und
unterschiedliche Entwicklungsstadien
auch diese Länder jede Stunde wird 1,2
Menschen Mensch geboren und wir bleiben
länger und bleiben gesünder wieso finde
ich unsere einzige Chance also der
Ressourcenverbrauch wird zunehmen ob das
Materialien ob das Energie ist das wird
zunehmen weil die Länder wachsen wollen
und für sich genau das gleiche erreichen
wollen wie
auch ohne Ressourcen also ohne
Zerstörung mit Kreislaufwirtschaft wir
müssen die Natur als Ressource begreifen
erneuerbare Energie Biodiversität etc
aber die Natur ist auch Gefahr und
insofern sollten wir alle nicht so naiv
sein also Natur ist Ressource und Gefahr
und das gehört einfach zusammen gedacht
das ist ja ein schönes Schlusswort
zumindestens als Anregung wie man mit
dieser mit diesen Problemen dass er
wirklich ein sehr großes Problem ist
vielleicht das größte Problem der
Menschheit auch weiter umgeht ich
bedanke mich bei mir Wecker weil
letztens und bei Daniel Gräber die
Deutsche Bahn Liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe
Zuschauer hat es leider nicht geschafft
uns auch noch Pauline Brünger von
Fridays for future hier vorbeizubringen
sie hat es nicht mehr geschafft ins
Studio zu kommen Sie gerne hier bei uns
gehabt zu diesem Thema es ging ja um den
Klimagipfel in Sharm el Sheikh und
die nächste aktuelle
phönix-sendung das ist unter den Linden
am kommenden Montag um
22:15 Uhr mit Thomas geh Becker jetzt
wartet an seiner fitkau mit Phoenix der
Tag bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]
Phoenix persönlich
wie gefährlich die internationale
Sicherheitslage ist haben die
raketeneinschläge in Polen gezeigt bei
mir ist Professor Karl Schlögl
renommierter